(audience applauding)
Please welcome back to the show, Ike Barinholtz.
Hello, Ike, how are you?
I'm good, I'm getting closer and closer
to you guys in person.
Last time was a zoom in my bedroom, and now it's here.
The next time, it's gonna be there.
You guys will smell me.
And there will be a next time.
This is our second time doing the show together.
I love doing the show with you.
I'm such a big fan of all of your movies,
and I'm so excited for this new cartoon.
But what did you love about growing up in Chicago?
And like, what's a memory from that?
I mean, Chicagoans have a very good sense of humor.
They like to make fun of people
and they love to get made fun of, you know,
like when you goof on someone from Chicago,
like someone in New York might punch you,
someone in Chicago is like,
"Yeah, that's true, that's true, you got me."
(Drew and audience laugh)
But, so, you know, comedy kind of flows through there.
You know, growing up there, I think the most fun part
was we had amazing athletes.
Like I grew up right near Wrigley Field
so I used to see the Cubs at like at the IHOP,
and then, you know, I was a huge Chicago Bulls fan.
You would go to a restaurant
and see Scottie Pippen somewhere.
So I think the sports of it all
is really what defines my childhood in Chicago.
Well, that's funny because like
you yourself played a lot of basketball, right?
We used to play.
If you grew up in Chicago in the 90s,
you just always had a basketball with you.
You would always dribble.
And there was this kind of health club where my friends
would all play at and they had games going on.
And every day we would go in
and be the same group of guys at these games,
and there was this one guy who always,
we always would see him and he was just
a really nice skinny dude.
And then like eight years later,
he ran for president as Barack Obama
and won.
So yeah, yeah, yeah.
(audience applauding)
So there he is, that's him.
And he's, A, he's really good,
but it's funny because he's always kind of like
very calm and cool, and you know,
that's his, he's unflappable, but I remember very well,
like one time we were playing, and he went up for a shot
and my buddy, Dave Stassen, fouled him
and President Obama came down and turned to my friend
and goes, "Don't you undercut me kid.
I am watching you."
And I was like, "Whoa ho ho ho."
So years later, whatever, I would see him.
I'm like, "Oh wow, I've seen that guy
get really mad before."
Oh, my gosh, I mean, I can't even believe,
but you eventually left Chicago and you made your way
to Los Angeles
Yes.
and you had been there for a while and you had
like a first audition, right?
Yeah, I mean, you know you move to LA and you're like,
"I'm ready for the big time.
I'm ready for stardom."
So there's a commercial first for Quiznos.
And I get there and I'm so excited.
I think I might've, you know, worn like nice slacks.
(Drew laughs)
And I remember
getting in there and this director,
he kind of looked at us and he was pitching us
as if he was James Cameron pitching avatar,
Right.
like it was so high concept.
And he's like, "Here's the deal guys,
Quiznos oven toasts they're subs.
So the concept of this commercial is
you're a vegetable
(Drew laughs)
or a piece of meat or cheese, and, and when I yell action,
that is the toasting starting to happen.
So do whatever inspires you, you know,
do some, some beat poetry or start dancing
or do blue man group or improv stuff."
And I was like, "Those aren't really the same,
but whatever."
And, but I did it and I was an onion
and I remember giving it my all
and I just started kind of like dancing and screaming.
And as we walk out, the guy said,
"Great job, I'll see you tomorrow."
And I remember calling my parents and being like,
"Well guess what, your son made it.
I made it in Hollywood because I'm gonna be an onion
in a Quiznos commercials,
(Drew laughs)
so call the relatives."
And then I went back the next day and, and I didn't get it.
Someone else was the onion, and it sent me into a spiral
and I didn't have another audition for a year and a half.
So never give up on your dreams, kids.
That's why I (indistinct).
(audience applauds)
Well, you know, speaking of your family,
Chicago Aunt Party
was inspired
by a Twitter account.
Yes, yeah, our buddy, Chris Witaske,
created this Twitter account like 10 years ago,
and it was just this really funny, inappropriate,
older woman who drinks too much
and has had this like lifelong party going on.
And we just thought it was like kind of fun and, you know,
a funny person to interact with.
And we never thought that it would really turn
into anything, and then like a few years ago,
Netflix was like, "Hey, we want to turn this
into 16 episodes of TV show."
We're like, "Oh, cool."
And is there anyone in the show
that's based on anyone from your family or childhood?
Well, I mean, that's the thing is that
this character is an aunt and it's kind of loosely based
off of our friend Chris's aunt,
but everyone has that person in your family who,
whenever they show up, you're like nervous
that they're going to say something inappropriate
and maybe ruin the meal, but they're really fun.
It could be an uncle,
(Drew gasps)
like right away, you know who it is, right?
You have someone like that?
Well, I got excited
'cause I know I'll like this person.
Yes.
Like if they're
the inappropriate one, I'm like, "Sit me next to them."
That's the thing.
If you don't know who in your family, that person is,
it is you, and which is good.
(audience laughs)
That's good, we love that, and...
(audience applauds)
It is me.
Yeah.
It is.
It's Aunt Drew.
It is, it's Aunt Drew.
Yeah, Aunt Drew's coming over, oh boy.
I wonder what she's gonna say.
Yup, exactly.
That's basically what the show's about.
It's also loosely inspired by you, too.
(Drew laughs)
I heard that somebody has something for me?
I have no idea what this is, is this true?
It's a little surprise.
It was flown in first class
about three hours ago.
Oh, my gosh.
but there it is, there it is, right there.
Sorry, Angel, I had no idea you were gonna be there.
So last time I was on your show,
I taught, I told you that for Thanksgiving,
I make stuffing with pastrami.
So I've sent you my recipe for Thanksgiving stuffing
made with pastrami.
Oh, my gosh, I can't,
I did not.
Here we go, get in there.
Look at that guys, look at that, look at that.
And I would not stop talking about it
because my favorite food is stuffing.
And I don't understand why everybody calendars it
into like one moment of the year.
Stuffing should be 365.
We need to open a stuffing-based restaurant in Los Angeles
Oh, my God.
or New York City
where you come in and it's three stuffings
and a couple of daily stuffing specials
and a dessert stuffing, and that's the whole restaurant.
(audience laughs)
Right?
We did it.
Oh my gosh, Ike.
Yeah.
This is incredible.
I will start looking for financiers
immediately
(Ike laughs)
for our stuffing themed restaurant.
First of all, I would eat there every day.
We're doing it, and everyone in the audience,
you're all invited to the opening night.
(audience applauds)
We're doing it.
It's happening.
(upbeat outro music)